HOW-TUBE.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
I'M GLAD YOU'RE EXCITED
BECAUSE IF YOU WANT TO LEARN HOW
TO DO SOMETHING, YOU SHOULD DO
ANYTHING BUT GO TO YOUTUBE.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU A FEW
SECONDS FROM A TUTORIAL VIDEO,
AND YOU TELL ME WHAT YOU THINK
THE FUNNY SUBJECT OF THE VIDEO
SHOULD BE.
IF YOUR ANSWER MAKES US LAUGH,
THEN YOU GET 250 POINTS.
IF NOT, THEN NO POINTS.
SO HERE'S THE FIRST ONE.
("CRAZY IN LOVE" PLAYING)
YES, HANNIBAL?
>> HOW TO RUIN HALLOWEEN FOR
EVERYBODY.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS, POINTS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
LET'S FIND OUT WHAT IT ACTUALLY
WAS.
>> FIRST THING, YOU HAVE TO
COVER UP YOUR FACIAL HAIR.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: YOU CAN JUST COVER UP
YOUR GOATEE WITH MAKEUP, RIGHT?
THAT'S HOW THAT WORKS.
>> SPRAY-ON STUFF.
>> Chris: YEAH, JUST THE
SPRAY-ON STUFF.
SEE, NOW YOU KNOW.
YOU GOT A GOATEE, NOW YOU KNOW.
>> I CAN USE IT TO JUST SHAVE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> THAT'S SMART.
>> Chris: NEXT ONE, NEXT ONE.
>> (in British accent): HI,
I'M ANDREW.
>> AND THIS IS SHANE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT
BRAIN TRUST IS ALL ABOUT,
HANNIBAL?
>> HOW TO MURDER YOUR FRIEND IN
THE WOODS UNDER THE GUISE OF
MAKING A YOUTUBE VIDEO.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS, POINTS FOR
SURE.
LET'S FIND OUT WHAT THIS
ACTUALLY IS.
>> TREMENDOUS BLOW TO THE
GENITAL AREA.
(LAUGHTER)
>> AT THAT POINT, THE GRIZZLY
WILL HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO TURN
AROUND AND WALK AWAY WITH HIS
NADS IN PAIN.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: OR YOU COULD REPEL
THE BEAR WITH BAD BRITISH
ACCENTS.
ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE.
>> TO GET HOW YOU WANT IT,
EVERYTHING GOT TO BE PRACTICED.
>> Chris: YES, ABBI?
>> OKAY, I THINK THIS IS HOW TO
GET ME, ABBI LEE JACOBSON, TO
IMMEDIATELY WANT TO GIVE YOU MY
PHONE NUMBER.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: REALLY?
>> IT'S HAPPENED BEFORE.
>> Chris: OKAY, GOOD, FINE, I'LL
GIVE YOU POINTS FOR THAT.
LET'S FIND OUT WHAT THIS
ACTUALLY IS.
>> GET EVERYTHING RIGHT, YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> SEE?
>> Chris: HOW ARE YOU FEELING
NOW?
>> WHERE IS THIS PERSON?
(LAUGHTER)
>> I CAN DO THAT RIGHT HERE.
>> Chris: YOU SAID THIS HAS
HAPPENED BEFORE A LOT?
HE'S RIGHT THERE!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> SO HANNIBAL, YOU HAVE MY
NUMBER ALREADY.
>> I GOT IT, I GOT IT.
>> Chris: SO YOU HAVE WATCHED
THIS VIDEO, THEN.
>> I WATCHED THIS VIDEO, YEAH,
MAN.
>> Chris: WELL, POINTS TO
HANNIBAL BURESS.
I GOT TO GIVE YOU POINTS FOR
THAT.
>> I'M WEARING A HEAVY SWEATER.
>> CAN WE DO IT?
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE.
>> WHAT'S UP, EVERYBODY?
WELCOME BACK TO MY VIDEO
TUTORIAL.
(SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE)
>> Chris: YES, ABBI?
>> HOW TO PUT ON GLASSES?
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: I WILL GIVE YOU POINTS
FOR THAT.
BY THE WAY, THIS LITERALLY COULD
BE HOW TO PUT ON GLASSES.
WHAT IS IT?
>> PUT IT ON, TRY IT ON AND GET
STUCK AND YOU'RE LIKE, "WHAT CAN
I DO?" AND IT HURTS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> CHRIS, I THOUGHT THAT WAS HOW
TO REINVENT YOURSELF AS A
RUSSIAN SCIENTIST WHEN YOU'RE
GEORGE ZIMMERMAN.
(LAUGHTER)